それで仏教のお話に入ります
悪いことはしやすいという
仏教は生命の実態を明かすんです
分析してみるんです 生命を
神話を持ってくるんじゃなくて
知ることは生きること
まあ生きるということは何やというと
知るというたった一つの機能なんです
これは何回何回も繰り返していますから
あの あまり難しくないと思います
自分の主観で 自分の都合で
自分が生きるために知ることをします
我々は生きるということは知るということで生きているんです
私もミミズも 知る機能があります
私はご飯見たら美味しい食べ物やと思っちゃうし
ミミズは腐りかけている枯れ葉とか土を見て
これが美味しいだな ご馳走だなと思ったりする
自分の都合で ミミズのミミズにはご馳走だから
なんで私が食べないんですかと
そうはなりません そういうわけで
それぞれの生命が自分の都合で環境を知って生きているんです
それで主観で知っているんです
ものを見ると 自分に食べられるということが認識したら食べ物にする
まあ例えばもうゴミがある
ゴミも食べる生命はいるんですけど
しかし 我々はゴミを見て
あ 食べ物だと思わないんです
だから世界を知ってどのように判断するのかというと
自分の都合で判断する
だから自分の都合なんです
だからカラスはゴミ箱を捨てて
ゴミを争うんだといってすごく困ったんだと
東京からカラスを全部退治しなくちゃいけないんだぞとかね
えらいことを言ってますけど
だから 東京の方々から見れば
カラスが悪人で悪いことをしているんですね
ずいぶん勝手にそう思っちゃいます
もうカラスは全然悪いことしてないんです
カラスはもうカラスの都合で物事を見て考えて生きているんです
それで人間は人間の都合で物事を見て考えているんです
そこでそれぞれの主観です
カラスに聞いてみたら
もうなんでこれ食べて悪いんですかと
いうことになるでしょうね
これ食べていかんだったら
あなたの家で飼っている猫でも持っていきますかと
別にどうってこと？カラスには猫っていうのはね
すぐ食べられますよ 猫は体でぶでいたんだからといってカラスが攻撃したら死にますから
だからカラスの立場から見れば
捨てた生肉を持って行って何も悪くない
カラスの立場から見れば
人間がそれを焼却処分するんですね
それってとんでもない悪行為でしょうね
もし説法はカラスがしたならば大変なことになります
生ゴミは焼却処分してはならないと
それっていうのはとんでもない悪行為だと
人間が説教しているんだから
カラスは悪いもんであって
思ったりして カラスのことをすごい差別する
だから事実は何なのかで
誰もこの 3番目の立場で見ようとしないんです
いわゆる中道で中世で物事を見ないんです
自分が知った通りに生きるしかないんです
それから我々にとってはもうどうしようもない
自分が知った通りに生活するしかないんです
例えば何か音が耳に入ると
気持ち悪い音 気持ち悪い音だと知ったならば
なおさら聞きましょう
ヘッドフォンをつけてこの音を聞きましょうということにはならないんです
気持ち悪い音だから なんとかその音を消してやるぞと
あるいは聞かないことにするぞとかいうふうに生活を変えるんです
だから私たちはやっていることすべて
自分が知ってからやっているものなんです
それで良いと思ってやっているんです
どんなことでも 例えば
自分があのどこかから何かもう破れている
もうぐちゃぐちゃになっているポスター一つ拾ったりしましょう
あちこち破れてもいるし
ぐにゃぐにゃになってもいるし
しかし ある人がそのポスターをちょっと手で伸ばして
あのしわしわいっぱいあるのありのままも
また破れたところはそのまま置いておいて
あのフレーム買ってきて
それをフレームにつけて額に入れて自分の部屋に飾るかもしれませんよ
誰かがなんでこんなゴミあなた持ってきたのに思ったっても意味がないんです
その人にとってはそれでよしということなんです
それでかっこいいと そういうわけで
我々やっているすべての行為
この無意識的にやっている行為さえも
まぶたを閉じたり 唾液
唾液というんですか 飲み込んだり
やっていることさえも同じことなんです
それでよしと思ってやっているんです
そういうわけで 何言いたいかというと
我々は知っている 要は知る
この知った通りに生きているのです
それはもうどうすることもできない羽目になっています
例えばお腹が空いたところで
家にある食べ物は何でしょうかと
もう何か見て何か見つかる
あ これは食べられそうと
食べられそうと思って
また下下の方を見たら
賞味期限はもう 1週間も経っている
そこでその人はどのように知るのかと
その賞味期限が 1週間経ってあっても食べられるんだと
どうったことないと思う人は食べる
あるいはちょうど例えば 23日まででしたならば
賞味期限がある人がちょうど 23日夜12時で
この瞬間からこれ食べられませんよという感じで
これは食べられません
気持ち悪い その人はそれを捨てたりする
決して賞味期限切れてあって
なんかもう膨らんだりもしているのに
これは気持ち悪い これはすぐ食べたらお腹が壊すかもしれません
だから食べますよということはありえないんです
食べる人はちょっとなんか匂いがありますけど
大丈夫 これぐらいではと思って食べるんです
だから自分を正しいと思って行動するしか
他の方法は成り立たないんです
その生き方が自分にとって正しいということになります
だから 自分が主観で知る
勝手に知る 勝手に知って
それが正しいと思って生きているんです
そういうわけで この自分が正しいという問題がすごい大きい問題なんです
自分が正しいという錯覚に必ず陥るんです
どうにもなりません 我々はいつでも自分が正しいという
ゴキブリはある 自分の家にいる
自分が正しい そのことになります
自分の生き方が他に他の生命の迷惑になる
だからどうなるのかというと
自分の生き方がその他
その他大勢の生命の迷惑になるんです
他の生命の生き方が自分にとって迷惑になる
だから自分の生き方はその他大勢の生命に迷惑でしょうし
その他大勢の生き方が自分にとってもすごい迷惑なんです
川に行って魚釣ろうかなと思っちゃうと
魚がなかなかこの疑似餌を食ってくれない
えらい失礼な態度ですね
魚が取っているのは それでもずっと 1時間とかね
2時間とかのバカがずっと釣り竿を持って待たなくちゃいけないんです
で そういうふうな生き方なんですよ
自分の餌を食ってくれない魚が悪いと
もし釣り竿を出した途端
さっ ぱっぱっぱっと魚が食べていくならば
ならばもう釣り 次から次へと釣るんです
そうすると自分が釣れてるんだ
幸せだ 幸福だと思ってますけど
大勢の他の生命にすごい迷惑かけてます
というわけで 魚の生き方は人間にとって迷惑でしょうし
人間の生き方は魚にとってすごい迷惑なんです
しかし 結果を気にせず
自分で正しい生き方をするんです
結果を気にすることは不可能です
今正しいと思ったことをやるしかないんです
だから 賞味期限過ぎて 2 日間も経ってるんだけど
自分にはどう見たってもこれは食べられると認識したら
もう食べますよ 食べ other のないんです
もう食べ物ないんだから
それ取ったでしょうに
お腹が空いた もう外へ行って食べることもできない
何か条件があって それで家に何かあったら取って食べるぞと言ったら
見たらこれしかない だから食べなくちゃいけないっていう認識がある
それでなおさらそこを熱処理してデータを
ああ これ食べても大丈夫やとって思って食べるでしょうに
で 食べたらどんな結果になるのかっていうことは考える余裕はないんです
というか 考えられないんです
だから どんな生命もいろんな行為をして生きているだけで
行為にどんな結果になるかっていうことは気にしない
で 普通に見れば 私の生き方は他の生命の生き方にすごい迷惑
他の生命の生き方は私にとってまた迷惑
なのに我々は何の注意もなく
すごい気楽に生きているのです
愚痴に気づかないので
悪は自然な行為になるんです
悪が本能です そこでまあ
これ私は今日紹介しないんだけど
愚痴というんです まああとちょこ説明あります
知るのは生命ですけど
正しく知るんじゃなくて
誤って知ってるんで 知ったことは正しくないんです
だから我々の認識 我々の知る世界は完全に愚痴なんです
だから私は知っているということは
承知と誤字という 2つに分けて大体説明していくんです
それで私の知は誤字な間違っている
で 間違ってるんだったら
その知識に基づいて行動するんだから
行動も間違っている しかし
私には他のことをできません
お腹がとても空いている
どうしようもない 何か食べなくちゃいけない
それで見つけたのは 2 日間賞味期限を取っているもの
で それでそれでこれで大丈夫だと決める
そうすると食べるしかほか態度ないんですよ
それが本能というものでしょ
あの音はきれいだと思ったら聞くしかない
この椅子に座ったら腰が痛くなるんだ
足が痛くなるんだもん
気持ちが悪くなるんだと思ったら立つしかないんです
この椅子はすごく腰が痛くなるし
足ももう痛くなるし だから座ってやるぞと
ずっと それはありえませんね
例えば何か化学製品で作った服を
美しい服を自分が着る
着たところで皮膚炎になる
あ これ着るともう皮膚炎になって痒くて痒くてたまらない
だからこれずっと着てやるぞということはありえませんね
すぐその服を脱ぐんです
そういうわけで 人間が愚痴に基づいて正しいと判断する行為をする
しかし これ愚痴が決めたんだから正しくないんです
というわけで 生命の本能はなんでしょうかね
間違っていることをすること
その他の生命に対してすごい迷惑をかけることなんです
自分のエゴで生きてみようとすることなんです
自分さえ良ければ こんなことは知らんと
他のことは知ったもんだもんですかという態度で生きることが本能なんです
皆様飼っている猫もそうなんです
自分の都合で生きているのであって
相手にはどうなるのかと
飼い主にどうなっているのか
そんなもう考えたこともないんです
そういうわけで 悪っていうのは生命の本能なんです
それはわかってないんです
ガヤガヤいろんなことを言っている人々は
だから新たに悪魔を設定する必要はありません
では 愚痴って何なのかというとね
眼耳鼻舌身意という ６つの感覚器官で色声香味触法という情報を知ることにするんです
この分析さえも仏教以外ないんです
普通は目でいろんなもの見えるでしょうと
目で見ていろんなことを知ることができると思ったら
それは勘違いで 目に入るのは単純な色というちょっとしたデータなんです
耳でいろんなことを美しい言葉とかね
大事な言葉とか聞こえないんで
それは頭で合成しなくちゃいけないんです
耳に聞こえるのは音だけです
そういうふうに客観的に分析したのは仏教なんです
入るデータは何なのかと
そこから語ってますから
で 互い違い感覚器官から入る互い違い情報を一つの概念認識として
意で合成する  ６番目の器官で
目に入る情報と舌に入る情報っていうのは全く互い違いなんです
しかし 私たちは ケーキを目で見て
いや なんて美味しいでしょう
見た目美味しいじゃなくて綺麗でしょうね
ケーキを見たら これかっこよかったな
これ結構綺麗ですと言うべきところ
あ 結構美味しそう 瞬間でえらいことを合成するものです
例えばテレビを見ると
テレビのキャスターたちが喋っていると思っているでしょう
口を開けたり いろいろなことをしたり
その本人の口から聞こえると勘違いしています
本人の口から全然聞こえませんよ
テレビ画面に映る人の口から
まあスピーカーは別で
そちらから音が聞こえるんですよ
面白いことは テレビのスピーカーを消して
別室にステレオをつなげて
他のちょっと遠いところに左右に置いておいたっても
そうすると当然こちら右から左から音を聞こえるし
一番前から映像を映しているし
それでも人が喋っていると思っている
それでも 今の機械だったらこれいくらでも実験できますよ
例えばこのこれぐらい大きい方になると
皆さん家ではないんだけど
あの大きい方ででも あのこちらでスクリーンをつけてテレビ画面をつけて
その後ろの方でスピーカーをつけても
みんな スクリーンをしている人が喋っていると思っているんです
合成するんです 各々の生命が各々の合成するんです
それから 5人仲間5人がテレビ番組を見ても
5人の認識が 5種類で
あなたと同じ気持ちになってやるぞということはありえないんです
頑張っています 同じ気持ちの仲間でみんな好きな同じ番組を見ようと
でもそれは成り立たないんです
それもまた互い違いです
それで それぞれの人の認識も互い違い
だから二人がいませんよ
同じことを考える 同じことを知っている人っていうのは
世の中  それがゴチの世界
自分が見た 聞いた 嗅いだ
味わった 触ってみた 理解したということになる
次に私は見た 聞いたと思っちゃうんですよ
自分の認識 概念 知ったことはその通りであり
事実であり 間違いないと結論になってしまう
よくみんな使っているでしょう
私が見たんだから間違いありませんと
私は食べてみたんだから
美味しいに決まっていると
間違いありません いつでも私は見た
聞いたという基準で正しいということになるんです
残念なことに みんなそれぞれ違うものを知っていますけど
5人で見てもらっても
5人も私は見た見ただから正しいと言ってますけど
5人が 5つのものを見ているんです
頭の中に 残念ながら この知識
経験は他の生命の知識
経験と同一にはならない
私は見たというより正しいと言ったっても
自分だけなんですけど
思っているのは 他の人は別な認識なんです
そういうことだから そちらもゴチということになるんです
無数の主観を合成しても
事実に真理に達しません
これよくやります  5人の意見を聞く
100人の意見を聞くとかね
よくテレビでもやっていますね
それに正しい意見はこれであると
そうは成り立ちません
1万人のゴチ 間違っている知恵をまとめて合成したら
それもなおさら間違っている
かなり間違っているんです
自分の概念にとらわれること
他人の概念に逆らうことなどはまた必然的に起こる
だから真理に達したいと思って
世の中の生命にバラの花を見せて
バラの花はどのように見えるのかと聞いて
みんなの意見を集めて合成して
コンピューターでデータ処理して結論を出しても真理になりません
だって自分にはコンピューター結果の通りに見えないでしょうし
まず 自分が正しいか コンピューターの結果が正しいかがわからなくなっちゃうでしょう
だからそれには信頼達することはできません
それから次の問題は 自分が知ってるだけが正しいんだから
他人が知ってる世界違うでしょうに
それに必然的に逆らいたくなります
だから人間の世界というのはいつでも意見違いで喧嘩する世界なんです
それで悩み 苦しみ 嫉妬
憎しみ 傲慢 エゴなどが必然的に起こるんです
次から次へと また心の中で一つ間違ったんだから
次から次へと転がってくるんです
因果法則であらゆる本能が
罪を犯す それから罪を犯すんです
自分で別に罪を犯すつもりもないんです
怒って悪いことをする
嫉妬していろんなことをする
自分が嫉妬さえも正しいと思いますよ
自分が怒ったらそれは正しい
当たり前です 当然だ 怒って当たり前
あんた人を殴ったでしょ
そうです 殴って当たり前
あいつは悪いんだから
そういう生き方をしているんです
それは愚痴から生まれるのです
それから どうにもなく
どうにすることもなく
自分が罪を犯す場合は
自分で管理できないでしょうに
だからこれは悪魔の誘惑であると
悪魔の悪魔に言う それから
それで悪魔の定義が 今言ったのは
なぜ世の中で悪魔の概念がずっと仏教でもあって
他の宗教であるのかというと
生命が本来そういう問題を持ってるんだからなんです
生命の本能が悪を犯すこと
怒ることは本能です 攻撃することは本能です
嫉妬することは生命の本能なんです
憎しみことは本能なんです
やりやすい なぜならば
何かやるために知らなくちゃいけない
知ろうと思ったら それは愚痴になっています
だからそういう避けられない
はめられている システムなんですよ
生命というのは 我々は眼耳鼻舌身という情報と
その感覚にはめられています
その中から抜けられないんです
だから起こす 犯すのはすべて罪悪ということになるんです
それが本能だから あまりなんの躊躇もなく自然にやっちゃう
だからそれが結果嫌になってくると
悪魔のせいにする 結果嫌になったらそれからこういう改良すればいいんだけど
その能力はないんです
それでなんで血は愚痴になるのかと
目は瞬間的に生滅変化しつつつつ流れる
例一つだけ説明します
目の例 目は瞬間瞬間変化していくんです
変わっていくんです 全く固体
固体として固定した目がありません
目がずっと変わらなきゃ目がありません
色見られるもの 見られるものも瞬間的に生滅変化しつつ流れるんです
目はずっと流れるわ 見るものもずっと変化して変わっていくわ
起こる眼識も瞬間的に生滅変化しつつ流れている
それで瞬間見えるでしょうに
瞬間見えて 次の瞬間別なものを見る
次の瞬間別なものを見るという
眼識さえもものすごいスピードで変化して流れているのです
3つも その変化の流れも因縁によって起こるので
永久的に変わらない流れでもありません
あるワンパターンで流れるならば
そこわかったということを言えますけど
ワンパターンでは流れません
例えば去年 5月 荒川が
荒川という川が溢れたと
洪水になったと だから今年 5月も
それはありえないんです
今年 5月は枯れてるかもしれません
だからこのワンパターンだったらなんとか把握できます
そうでもない 流れさえまた縁によって変わってしまいます
花を見たという知になるが
花を見た目も花も瞬間で変わって滅しているから
知識 概念として 私の意見考えとして何も成り成り立たない
成り立たないはずです
例えば 目が瞬間の目があって
瞬間で花を見る すぐその目が目がそれからないんで
別な目なんです 花も別の花なんです
瞬間で見た眼識ありますね
知ったということ だから私は花を見たんだ
知ってるんだということは言えないはずなんです
なぜならば その花はもうないんです
その花を見た目ももうないんです
そこで原因もなくないならば
結果だけあるってどういうこと？電気はなくなったんですけど
光はあるんだそうということ
ありえないでしょう 本当は血は成り立たないんです
でも気づかないんです
しかし 意で合成した概念はあるものを通して錯覚する
これ合成するでしょ 頭の中で
この合成したことが自分があると思っちゃうんです
いいかな この 花がある
私がいるではないかと変わらない
血が起こりません  方向間違えた
方向間違えちょっと うん
相手のはそれで花がある
それを見る私もいるという知識は現れないはずなんです
で 現れるんです ちょっとややこしいんだからすぐに行きます
ちょっと文章はちょっとややこしいんです
理由は私がいる 私がいると錯覚を成り立たない私がいる
ずっと変化するんだから
それでも私がいると思ってるんです
というのは 幻覚っていうのは変わらないんですよ
すべて無常なのに これで一つお釈迦様の言葉でルーパンジーレティマッチャーナンナーマゴッタンレジーレティという有名な言葉があります
人の体が朽ちていくが
名は朽ちないという意味なんです
で ブッダの言葉があります
人の体は因縁によって現れた現象なので
変化して消えることは当然ですから
人の肉体 体っていうのはもう当然生まれた瞬間から変化しているんですよ
存在もしない幻覚である
その人に付けた名前は変わらないんです
子供が生まれた瞬間で
一太郎と名前をつける
どこにも一太郎いるわけじゃないんです
ただ肉体でできている生命だけなんです
それが瞬間瞬間変わっていくんです
変わっていって 年取って死んでしまいます
しかし 一太郎っていうことは変わらないんですね
一太郎は小学校に行った
一太郎は高校に入った
一太郎は大学に入った
一太郎が入社しましたとか
一太郎が結婚しましたとか
一太郎が年取ったと 一太郎が病院に運ばれたと
一太郎が死んだって 変でしょう
全く変わってますよ 全部
瞬間瞬間 しかし 一太郎とつけた名前
それはどこにも存在しないんですよ
何の実体もないんです
だから実体がないんだから変化できんでしょう
だから我々は頭で合成する認識が幻覚ですよ
だから自分がいるということでずっとあるんです
したがって 我々の知識
認識 概念という知はものが私が実体としてある
いるという誤解 錯覚に陥っているんです
我々はずっと私がいるんだよという
名前はこれだよという錯覚できているんです
したがって 知は愚痴です
というわけで 知ということは愚痴になるんです
知は逆さま あべこべなのです
我々は知っているのは逆さまなんです
ないものをあると知っているんだから
苦なのに楽だ 無常なのに常住だ
無我なのに我があるのだと決めつけているんです
だからお釈迦様が人類にとって無常であるということは大胆な真理だよと革命的なものだよと言ったら
そういうわけ 我々は無常なのに無常は認識できん
常住だと思ってる なぜならば
認識っていうのは あの一太郎みたいな存在もしない錯覚なんです
合成したものなんです
それは仏教用語でヴィパッサナーと言うんですね
まあ転倒ということもありますけど
逆知なんです 私の私が使った使う単語で
1 チッタヴィパッサナー
心は逆にサンニャーヴィパッサナー
認識概念は逆  3 ディッティヴィパッサナー
見解は逆 というのが起こるんです
3種類です 心がもう逆に働く
逆を認識 それから心で認識しますからね
あるんだ あるんだとか
本当はないんです そちらの逆です
それから認識したものからいろんなアイディアが作るんです
悪魔がいるんだ 神様がいるんだとかね
そういう見解もすべて逆さま
逆という 貪瞋痴を柱として
たくさんの煩悩 感情がこれと幻覚によって現れる
それから千五百の煩悩が生まれるんです
この この逆力 あるんだと思っちゃうんだから
全部怒りも憎しみも生まれるんです
千五百煩悩は三本の大きな柱で説明してますね
貪瞋痴という どんな煩悩もこの三つに入ります
皆に同じ感情が起きるなら
事実だとスラスラすることもできますが
そうではありません 例えば
いいえ そんなこと言ったってもということを言えますよ
そうなりません 私が花を見て花は綺麗に決まってる
それは事実だ なぜでしょうか？誰が見たっても花が綺麗ですと言えるならばありがたいんだけど
そうじゃないんです 勝手
主観 自分の幻覚 他の人と別な幻覚を作る
だから世間見たらみんな意見バラバラでしょうに
好みバラバラでしょうに
感情バラバラでしょう
それが幻覚という証拠なんです
一つ例を出してみましょう
犬を見て一人が喜びを感じる
犬がいるとしましょう
それで犬を見たら 誰かがすごい可愛いと喜びを感じる
一人が気持ち悪いと怒りを感じ
気持ち悪いこの犬はもう一人が思ったりする
一人が怖いと怒りを感じる
もう一人は怖いと思ったりする
あの口がすごく変形している
涎を垂らしている犬が
何とかの犬がいるでしょ
え？かなり狂犬病かかってるみたい
あれあれ なんとか種類の犬ですね
え？ブルドッグとか またもう一つ種類ありますけど
で それ飼ってる人にとっては
あの口のあのカッコ悪さっていうのはもう可愛くてたまらないんですよ
しかし みんなあ これかっこいいと思わないんですよ
気持ち悪いと思う人もいる
時々ブルドッグというのは怖いと思う人もいる
ですから このもし犬という科学的な対象を見て
人間という生命にある特定の感情が生まれるというならば
一定しなきゃダメなんです
それ科学事実であるならば
ブルドッグを見たら人間怖くなるんだよっていうことは
科学事実だったら どんな人間見ても怖くなるはずなんです
全然感情だけはそうならない
バラバラです どんな気持ちになるかわからないんです
ということは その見た人が自分勝手に合成したということなんです
犬の肉を食べる人なら美味しいと感じるでしょう
あの結構犬の肉を食べてるみたいですよ
韓国とか それだったら可愛いブルドッグじゃなく
これ結構美味しそうだなと
肉が柔らかくてと思う可能性もあります
各自で主観で作った幻覚によって
各自に現れる感情も一定しないですから
そこでお釈迦様のすごいところは
いろんな生命に起こる感情を全部まとめて整理整頓しているんです
あなたにはどんな感情が起ころうとしても
貪瞋痴痴だよと そういうところで科学的な心理を発見するんです
あるいはもう伸ばして伸ばして計算してみたっても
まあ千五百程度だよと
だから私に犬を見て貪る欲が生まれるかもしれません
他の人に怒りが生まれかかるかもしれません
しかし 誰にも現れた いまだかつて現れたことがない感情が現れたということはありえないんです